WE ARE GRATEFUL TO BE WITH YOU
AT THIS AUGUST 14TH EDITION OF
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE. THIS
IS GOING TO BE OUR FIRST OUR
LAST COMMITTEE OF THE YEAR, AND
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT EACH OF YOU
ARE WITH US AS WE APPROACH THE
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINE HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE AND THE
LEGISLATURE. BEFORE WE MOVE ON
ANY OF TODAY'S BUSINESS, WHAT
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS
OPEN UP WITH A QUORUM CALL.
WE'RE GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT
OVER TO MADAM SECRETARY. MAGUIRE
HERE. MAGUIRE. HERE. GROVE.
GROVE. HERE. EGGMAN. EGGMAN!
HERE. JONES! I'M HERE. JONES,
HERE. LAIRD, HERE. LAIRD. HERE.
QUORUM. QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT OF PERSONAL PRIVILEGE TO
BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE TWO
INDIVIDUALS TODAY. AND THAT IS
FIRST AND FOREMOST, SENATOR
EGGMAN. SENATOR EGGMAN WILL BE
RETIRING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HERE AT THE END OF
THE YEAR. THIS IS GOING TO BE
HER FIRST, I KEEP SAYING FIRST
LAST RULES COMMITTEE, AND WE
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE
TO CELEBRATE HER, HER
DISTINGUISHED SERVICE. FIRST AS
A VETERAN, AS A SOCIAL WORKER,
AND OF COURSE, AS AN AMAZING
LEGISLATOR HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAS DELIVERED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN, TRULY THE
PRIDE OF STOCKTON. I THINK WE
NEED TO GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE, PLEASE. MY GOODNESS,
SAY THANK YOU. AND SPEAKING OF
VETERANS, I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR GROVE.
MADAM VICE CHAIR, IF THERE ARE
ANY ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO SAY, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. SO AS WE CAME IN
TOGETHER, IN 2010, IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY AND,
IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK WITH
YOU. WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE, BUT
WHAT I LOVE ABOUT YOU MOST AND A
FEW OTHER MEMBERS IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE CAN DISAGREE AND GET
INTO A KNOCKDOWN, DRAG OUT,
FISTFIGHT, AND THEN WE GO HAVE
CHAMPAGNE AND TALK AND LAUGH AND
TELL JOKES LATER, AND I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
HAS JOINED SENATOR ATKINS AND I
ON OUR DOLLY PARTON. GLEN
CAMPBELL, ALL THOSE SONGS, YOU
KNOW, WE ALL SING PRETTY GOOD
WITH A HAIRBRUSH IN OUR HAND AND,
BUT, ON A SERIOUS NOTE, I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR ONE, PUTTING
YOUR HAND IN THE AIR AND
SWEARING TO DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
AGAINST ALL ENEMIES, FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC AND PROVIDING EXCELLENT
SERVICE IN YOUR MILITARY CAREER.
AND THEN COMING BACK TO THE
CIVILIAN WORLD AND WORKING ON
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AS A SOCIAL
WORKER AND THEN COMING TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE AND
BEING ONE OF THE, IF NOT ONLY
THE LEADING CHAMPION OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICE WORKER
SOCIAL SERVICE. BECAUSE THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE DAMAGED. AND
YOU SAID ONE TIME IN A FLOOR
SPEECH YOU DON'T WANT TO SAY
DAMAGED BEYOND REPAIR, BUT THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIFFERENT
LIFE EXPERIENCES THAT CREATE
DAMAGE. AND YOU REALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE. AND THE LEGISLATION THAT
YOU'VE PUT FORTH IS, IS, IS,
GOING TO BE SO BENEFICIAL,
ESPECIALLY THE ONE THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED LAST YEAR? I,
IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK WITH
YOU, FELLOW VETERAN. I THINK THE
WAY YOU TAKE CARE OF YOUR FAMILY
IN ME AND RENEE IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY. YOU ARE RAISING
ONE INCREDIBLE YOUNG LADY THAT
IS. GOSH, GOT GOD'S OPEN DOORS
BEFORE HER. AND SHE REALLY IS
JUST AN AMAZING YOUNG WOMAN. AND
SO I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME SERVE WITH YOU. THANK
YOU FOR, BAILING ME OUT WHEN I
HAVE MY MELTDOWNS, ESPECIALLY
WHEN I WAS CONFRONTING THAT DRUG
DEALER ON THE STREET. YOU WERE.
YOU WERE AWESOME, SHE'S LIKE,
COME TO WORK. JUST GET IN THE
CAR AND COME TO WORK, AND SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE JUST, YOU'RE ONE
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA
BE HARD TO REPLACE, AND YOU
CAN'T BE REPLACEABLE BECAUSE NOT
ONLY ARE YOU A PROFESSIONAL, BUT
YOU'RE ALSO PERSONAL AND YOU'RE
A REALLY GOOD FRIEND. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU, MY FRIEND. THANK
YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR, I WOULD
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TURN IT OVER
TO DOCTOR EGGMAN FOR ANY
REMARKS. WELL. THANK YOU, I
DON'T KNOW ALL YOU PEOPLE, BUT
THANK YOU. GLAD YOU CAME TO MY
PARTY. NICE BUT JUST TO THANK
THIS BODY, I'VE REALLY HAVE ONLY
BEEN ABLE TO DO RULES FOR A
YEAR. BUT I THOROUGHLY HAVE
ENJOYED IT. THE DELIBERATION AND
ALWAYS THE PROFESSIONALISM OF
THE STAFF AND THE MEMBERS AND
OUR BEHAVIOR. I THINK THIS
REALLY HELPS. I MEAN, IT IT
PROVIDES A DIFFERENT VIEW.
PEOPLE ALWAYS THINK OF POLITICS
AS VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL AND NOT
WORKING, AND I THINK WE JUST
PROVIDE A LOVELY MODEL OF PEOPLE
WHO RESPECT EACH OTHER AND ARE
REALLY INTERESTED IN DOING THE
PEOPLE'S WORK, WHO COME TOGETHER
AND GET IT DONE. SO I HAVE
APPRECIATED MY TIME WITH EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU, AS WELL AS
THE STAFF, AGAIN, TO THANK YOU
AND ALL OF US. SO THANK YOU. I'M
GOING TO MISS IT. I'M GOING TO
MISS IT. IT'S BEEN A GOOD RUN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND BEST DAYS
ARE STILL AHEAD. AND REALLY
GRATEFUL, SENATOR EGGMAN. AND IF
WE COULD PLEASE GIVE SENATOR
EGGMAN ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE
AND SAY THANK YOU. MY GOODNESS.
I'M GRATEFUL. THANK YOU. WE ALSO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR COMMITTEE SECRETARY CHINOOK
HAS BEEN DELIVERING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR OVER 30
YEARS. IN FACT, 33 TO BE EXACT.
SHE HAS SERVED THIS LEGISLATURE,
BOTH IN THE ASSEMBLY, IN THE
SENATE, AND THE BEST THING THAT
HAS EVER HAPPENED TO THE SENATE
IS RIGHT BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
HIT, CHINOOK CAME BACK TO BE
ABLE TO FINISH HER CAREER. SHE
IS PROFESSIONAL. SHE IS BUTTONED
UP, TENACIOUS AND CANDIDLY, THIS
COMMITTEE AND EVERYTHING THAT WE
DO WOULD FALL APART WITHOUT HER.
YES, AND SHE IS TRULY ONE OF THE
BEST. AND WE CANNOT SAY THANK
YOU ENOUGH. AND I THINK WE NEED
TO GIVE HER A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
AND SAY THANK YOU FOR HER
SERVICE. I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MADAM VICE
CHAIR, AS WELL AS TO THE
SECRETARY. MADAM VICE CHAIR.
PLEASE. ANY REMARKS. WELL, ALL
THAT YOU SAID, I JUST AFFIRM
WHAT YOU SAID. AND CHINOOK, YOU
KNOW, I SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE
WITH YOU FOR FOUR YEARS NOW, AND
YOU REALLY ARE THE WHEEL. YOU
ARE THE WHAT MAKES THE WHEELS
MOVE IN THIS COMMUNITY. AND EVEN
WHEN THEY LEAVE ME THE MIC,
WHICH IS JUST BEYOND COMPARE,
WHY THEY WOULD GIVE ME THE MIC,
IT'S UNDER MY, WHAT DO YOU CALL
IT? MY GOVERNORSHIP, WHAT DO YOU
CALL IT? YEAH. MY
ADMINISTRATION. SO WHEN THEY
LEAVE ME HERE AND I'M IN CHARGE
AND IT'S MY ADMINISTRATION, YOU
DON'T LET ME MISS A BEAT. AND
YOU ARE, YOU ARE JUST REALLY
INCREDIBLE. AND FOR YOU TO COME
BACK AFTER COVID TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE STILL HAD THE ORDER IN
THE HOUSE THAT WE NEEDED BECAUSE
THE RULES COMMITTEE IS A VITAL
PART OF OUR PROCESS AND RUNNING
THE HOUSE AND FOR YOU TO DO THAT
AND GIVE UP THOSE THAT FOUR
YEARS OF YOUR TIME AND WITH YOUR
FAMILY RETIREMENT AND ALL THAT
KIND OF STUFF, THAT JUST SHOWS
THE KIND OF LEADER THAT YOU ARE
AND THAT YOU REALLY DO DEEPLY
CARE ABOUT THIS STATE. SO THANK
YOU. WE WILL MISS YOU, BIG SHOES
TO FILL, FOR WHOEVER'S COMING UP
BEHIND YOU. BUT WE JUST THANK
YOU FOR ALL YOUR DEDICATE 30
YEARS TO THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU.
THANKS. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NOW,
I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE SECRETARY OF
SENATE. ERIKA CONTRERAS. SO I'LL
JUST CLARIFY THAT, WHEN WE HIRED
CHINOOK, SHE ACTUALLY WAS HIRED
TO DO A DIFFERENT JOB. SHE DID
NOT ANTICIPATE THAT SHE WAS
GOING TO BE HELPING THE RULES
COMMITTEE DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. AND SO I WAS JUST VERY
GRATEFUL THAT THREE WEEKS INTO
HER JOB, WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT,
SHE AGREED TO STAY WITH US, AND
REINVENT THE SENATE, SO THAT WE
COULD CONTINUE TO SERVE THE, THE
PUBLIC, THAT WE COULD, WORK WITH
OUR RULES COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATURE AND REINVENT
OURSELVES IN A WAY THAT ALLOWED
THE LEGISLATORS TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC AND PASS A BUDGET AND
APPROVE ESSENTIAL LEGISLATION
DURING THOSE YEARS THAT WE WERE
IN CRISIS. AND SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMITMENT AND
YOUR HELP AND FOR NOT RUNNING
AWAY AFTER THOSE THREE WEEKS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
SO MUCH, CHINOOK, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR AMAZING WORK. WE WERE JUST
TALKING HOW YOU'RE FEELING, AND
YOU SAID, I'M REALLY EXCITED.
PLEASE, WE'RE GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO YOU IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SAY ANY WORDS. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SAY ANYTHING? NO. ALL RIGHT.
SEE, THERE WE GO. BELIEVE ME.
SHE SAID SHE'S REALLY EXCITED.
THERE WE GO. AM I RIGHT? YES.
YES. AND IT IS AN EMOTIONAL TIME
AS WELL. AND JUST ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTIRE COMMITTEE, WE WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR SERVING THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. CAN WE
PLEASE GIVE HER A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE? CHINOOK IS GOING TO
WHOOP UPSIDE THE HEAD AFTER THIS
BECAUSE SHE DOES NOT LIKE THE
SPOTLIGHT. SO HEY, THERE WE GO.
BUT THANK YOU. AND
CONGRATULATIONS, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN. COMMITTEE. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR AS WELL. AND TO
MADAM SECRETARY FOR THOSE
BEAUTIFUL WORDS OF BOTH. WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO LOOK TOWARDS
OUR AGENDA AND FOCUS ON THE
BUSINESS OF OUR DAY. WHAT WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO DO IS TAKE UP
SOME ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS HERE.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
APPOINTEES WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE ITEMS, AND
WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO OUR FIRST
BOOK OF BUSINESS. FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS ITEM NUMBER TWO.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO SEE IF THERE'S A
MOTION. SO MOVED. WE HAVE A WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MADAM VICE
CHAIR. PLEASE, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
E F G H AND I. YES. TOGETHER.
YES, PLEASE. E THROUGH I TO E
THROUGH I TO E THREE. I TO E
THROUGH I. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MADAM VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE. MAGUIRE. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0. IT'S
A50 VOTE. FIVE ZERO VOTE. THAT
MOTION PASSES. WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE MOVING ON TO BILL
REFERRALS. IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE? SO MOVED. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MADAM VICE CHAIR.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MAGUIRE. MAGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE. I. GROVE. I. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. I. JONES. JONES I. LAIRD
I, LAIRD. I. 5 TO 0. THAT'S A50
VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES. WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO
RURAL WAIVER. WAIVER REQUEST?
EASY FOR ME TO SAY. ITEM FOUR IS
A REQUEST BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE 61 TO ALLOW
AB 157, 158 AND 176 THROUGH 185
TO BE HEARD IN THE COMMITTEE
DURING THE BLACKOUT PERIOD. IS
THERE A MOTION? AYE. SO MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
LAIRD. MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE.
MAGUIRE? AYE. GROVE. NO. GROVE.
NO. EGGMAN EGGMAN. AYE. JONES.
NO. JONES. NO. JONES. NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. 3 TO 2. THREE
TO VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE MOVING ON
TO COMMITTEE APPOINTMENTS.
CHANGES TO COMMITTEE
APPOINTMENTS. ITEMS FIVE THROUGH
12. REMOVING SENATOR ALVARADO
GIL FROM ALL COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS. LEAVING A VACANCY
IN THOSE COMMITTEES TO BE FILLED
AT A DATE TO BE DETERMINED. WE
WILL SEEK A MOTION. I MOVE ITEMS
FIVE THROUGH 12. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR LAIRD. MADAM
SECRETARY, MAY I SPEAK TO THE
MOTION? OH, YES, PLEASE. LEADER
JONES, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A,
INTERESTING TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO HAVE A MEMBER
CHANGE PARTIES, AND I KIND OF
UNDERSTAND THE REASONING BEHIND
THE COMMITTEE CHAIR POSITION. I
WOULD HOPE THAT, YOU KNOW, THERE
IS PRECEDENT IN THE SENATE FOR A
REPUBLICAN TO HOLD A CHAIR OF A
COMMITTEE, I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THIS IS NECESSARILY THE
COMMITTEE THAT WE WOULD
PARTICULARLY ASK TO HAVE A
CHAIRMANSHIP OF, BUT I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN GET BACK TO THAT
PRECEDENT AT SOME POINT IN TIME.
I'M I'M DEEPLY CONCERNED AND
OPPOSED SPECIFICALLY TO THE
REMOVAL OF ALL THE REMAINING
COMMITTEES, SENATOR ALVARADO GIL
REPRESENTS A MILLION
CONSTITUENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SHE HAS A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IN HER
AREA. IN ADDITION TO AND
INSURANCE, IN ADDITION TO OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT SHE SERVES ON.
SHE HAS AN IMPORTANT VOICE TO
LEND TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
OF CALIFORNIA AND TO THIS HOUSE
AND TO THE LEGISLATURE. IN TOTAL.
AND I WILL BE, I WILL SAY,
FIGHTING, ARGUING. ADVOCATING,
THAT SHE BE PUT ON VERY SPECIFIC
COMMITTEES GOING DOWN THE ROAD
FROM HERE. BUT I AM I AM A
LITTLE BIT DISAPPOINTED IN THIS
ACTION TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LEADER JONES, APPRECIATE THAT.
PLEASE, MADAM VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU, MISTER CHAIR. I DO CONCUR
WITH LEADER JONES'S COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A LATINA
WOMAN, WE'RE LOOKING AT PARITY
FOR US AS LEGISLATORS IN THE IN
THE BODY TO GET PARITY SO THAT
WOMEN CAN HAVE THEIR POSITIONS
IN THIS BODY, WE HAVE A LATINA
WOMAN WHO IS BEING OSTRACIZED
AND, REMOVED FROM COMMITTEES.
EVERY OTHER REPUBLICAN, EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S ONLY, WELL,
THERE'S NINE OF US NOW, BUT
THERE'S ONLY EIGHT OF US BEFORE
WE ALL SERVE ON COMMITTEES THAT
REPRESENT OUR DISTRICTS. YOU'VE
BEEN VERY GRACIOUS IN MAKING
SURE THAT WE SIT ON COMMITTEES
THAT THAT ARE ASSOCIATED TO OUR
DISTRICT. SO THAT WE CAN HAVE A
VOICE FOR THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
ELECTED US TO BE HERE, ALL 40 OF
US, WHETHER YOU'RE IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY OR THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, REPRESENT ALMOST A
MILLION PEOPLE. AND TO TAKE
RETALIATORY, ACTION AGAINST
SENATOR MARIA ALVARADO GIL, I
THINK IS, NOT APPROPRIATE. AND
NOT WORTHY OF WHAT THIS BODY
SHOULD DO, SHE HAS A RIGHT TO
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE THAT SHE'S
BEEN VOTED IN BY AND REPRESENT
HER DISTRICT, AND SHE MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION WITH SOME
TIMES BOTH PARTIES, BUT SHE'S
DOING WHAT SHE WANTS TO DO, WHAT
SHE FEELS SHE NEEDS TO DO TO
REPRESENT HER DISTRICT. AND THAT
INCLUDES WHAT SHE DID LAST WEEK
AND THE VOTES THAT SHE TAKES.
SHE DOESN'T ALIGN WITH EITHER OF
US 100% OF THE TIME. AND TO TAKE
THIS ACTION, I THINK, IS
INAPPROPRIATE. AND I DO AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE, SENATOR
JONES, WHEN, SENATOR BURGESS WAS
GIVEN THE CHAIRMANSHIP OF
AGRICULTURE BECAUSE HE RAN THE
IT WAS THE TOP FOOD PRODUCING
COUNTY IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ACTUALLY, THE WORLD.
AND I KNOW THAT THE CHAIRMANSHIP
IS VERY IMPORTANT, ALMOST ALWAYS
HELD BY DEMOCRATS. SO I
UNDERSTAND THE REASON FOR
REMOVING HER FROM A
CHAIRMANSHIP. BUT FOR THE LIFE
OF ME, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
REMOVING HER FROM ALL THE
COMMITTEES. WE ALL SERVE ON
COMMITTEES AND WE ALL HAVE A
VOICE, AND WE ALL NEED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE THAT ELECT US. SO I JUST
I'LL BE VOTING NO AGAIN ON THESE
MOTIONS AS WELL. THANK YOU, SIR,
FOR LETTING ME SAY THAT. NO,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM VICE
CHAIR. THANK YOU, MISTER LEADER.
TODAY'S ACTION IS UNDER THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS. AND
WHEN THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE LIKE THE ONE WE HAD LAST
WEEK, WE NEED TO EVALUATE THE
BALANCE OF COMMITTEES, INCLUDING
THE SIZE AND GEOGRAPHIC MAKEUP.
WE'RE BEGINNING TO EVALUATE
THESE ISSUES, AND WE'LL BE BACK
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE IN
THE COMING WEEKS. AND THAT IS
ALSO SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
SHARED WITH LEADER JONES. AND
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT ON THAT.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE A MOTION ON
THE FLOOR BY SENATOR LAIRD AND
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. SO MUCH,
LEADER JONES AND MADAM VICE
CHAIR FOR THE COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM
SECRETARY. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? MAGUIRE. MAGUIRE? AYE.
GROVE. NO. GROVE. NO. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. NO. JONES.
NO. LAIRD. HI. LAIRD. AYE. 3 TO
2. IT'S A32 VOTE, AND THE MOTION
PASSES. THANK YOU. SO MUCH,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
COMMITTEE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING ON TO FLOOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS. IS THERE A
MOTION TO APPROVE? SO MOVED. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
MADAM SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE.
AYE. GROVE GROVE. AYE. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. JONES. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD. LAIRD. AYE. 5 TO 0. FIVE.
ZERO VOTE. THAT MOTION PASSES.
THANK YOU. SO MUCH. THAT IS NOW
GOING TO BRING US BACK UP TO THE
FIRST PART OF OUR BUSINESS.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
MEMBERS OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION. WE'RE GOING TO INVITE
EACH OF THE THREE TO BE ABLE TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE DAIS.
WE'LL TAKE A 32ND RECESS AS EACH
OF THE MEMBERS PLEASE COME
FORWARD. WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. WE'LL GET YOU
SITUATED AND WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE.
WELCOME. EXCUSE ME. EASY FOR ME
TO SAY. IT'S GOOD TO SEE EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU. AND I WANT
TO START OUT BY SAYING THANK YOU
SO MUCH TO THE SERVICE. LET'S
JUST BE HONEST. IT IS OFTEN A
THANKLESS JOB, AND IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT YOU DO ON
BEHALF OF THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF KIDS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE GOING
TO ASK EACH OF YOU TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE 1 TO 2 MINUTES OF AN
OPENING STATEMENT. DURING THAT
TIME, WE WELCOME YOU TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE ANY WELCOMING REMARKS
TO FRIENDS OR FAMILY WHO MAY BE
HERE IN THE AUDIENCE OR WATCHING
ONLINE. AFTER THAT, WE'RE GOING
TO OPEN IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND AGAIN, WE APPRECIATE EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF YOU FOR BEING
HERE. WE'RE NOW GOING TO HAVE
MISS BROWNSON START US OFF. WE
WELCOME YOU TO COMMITTEE. YOU
HAVE 1 OR 2 MINUTES. AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THANK YOU. IT'S ALREADY
ON. OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON. AND I
JUST WANT TO START BY THANKING
CHAIRMAN MCGUIRE AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE,
THANK YOU ALSO TO YOUR STAFF
FROM THE SENATE RULES
CONSULTANTS AND STAFF AND THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE STAFF WHO HAVE
HELPED US NAVIGATE THIS PROCESS.
AND LASTLY, I, OF COURSE, WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOM FOR PUTTING OUR NAMES
FORWARD, MUCH OF THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION'S WORK, I THINK,
CENTERS ON FAIRLY TECHNICAL
RULES AND REGULATIONS AND OUR
FORMAL WRITTEN APPLICATION. I
THINK, SPEAKS TO MUCH OF THAT.
BUT WHAT I REALLY WANTED TO
ANCHOR ON TODAY IS WHY THIS WORK
MATTERS, AND WHAT HAS REALLY
ANIMATED, NOT JUST MY INTEREST
IN CONTINUING TO SERVE ON THE
STATE BOARD OF ED, BUT REALLY MY
BROADER 20 PLUS YEAR CAREER IN
EDUCATION POLICY AND
IMPLEMENTATION, I THINK
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS OFFER
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STRONG BEGINNINGS, FOR
TRANSFORMATION AND FOR A BRAND
OF FAIRNESS THAT IS UNIQUELY
CALIFORNIAN, IN MY OWN CASE, I
WENT TO URBAN PUBLIC SCHOOLS,
LARGELY LOW INCOME PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. AND I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN KIDS
FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS. I HAVE
ALSO SEEN WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
WHEN THINGS WORK GLORIOUSLY
WELL, WHEN THE ADULTS ARE
ALIGNED, WHEN THE FOCUS IS
ALWAYS ON IMPROVEMENT AND MAKING
THE SYSTEMS WORK. AND IN MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE, I HAD THE
GREAT FORTUNE OF GRADUATING FROM
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND GOING OFF TO
HARVARD COLLEGE AND HAD THIS
EPIPHANY MOMENT WHEN I CAME BACK
AND FORTUITOUSLY RAN INTO MY
HIGH SCHOOL PRINCIPAL, MISS
MARION COLLINS, WHO WAS STILL A
LEGEND, AND IT WAS A MOMENT
WHERE SHE SAID TO ME, HOW DID WE
DO? DID WE PREPARE YOU, AND I
THINK EVERY, EVERY COLLEGE AND
HIGH SCHOOL KID KNOWS THAT THEY
DON'T DO IT ALONE, BUT I VERY
MUCH FEEL THE WEIGHT OF A DEBT
OF GRATITUDE TO THE PEOPLE AND
SYSTEMS THAT MADE MY OWN
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY POSSIBLE,
AND SEE INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITIES
AHEAD FOR THE NEXT GENERATION.
SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT WHAT WE
CAN DO IN THE FUTURE, THOSE
THOSE VALUES AROUND FAIRNESS AND
TRANSFORMATION AND STRONG
BEGINNINGS ARE WHAT I LOOK TO
FOR THE TERM TO COME. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MADAM BOARD
MEMBER. GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
HERE. WILL BE OPENING UP FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE IN JUST A MOMENT. MR.
MCQUILLAN, IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU.
SIR, YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU. I'D
SAY I Kò NICK NOW. JIM. YOU
GREET YOU IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE
YUROK PEOPLE. I'M JIM MCQUILLAN,
I'M HONORED TO BE ASKED TO BE
REAPPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
ALL OF YOU TO COME BACK AGAIN
FOR FOUR MORE YEARS ON THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. IT IS A LOT
OF WORK AND A LOT OF PREPARATION
ON TOP OF BEING A FULL TIME
EMPLOYEE. AND I OVERSEE TRIBAL
EDUCATION DEPARTMENT UP NORTH
WITH LOTS OF EMPLOYEES. I WANT
TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT TO MY
COPILOT IN THE BACK. MY WIFE
CHRISTINE IS IN THE BACK AND WE
MADE THE LONG DRIVE TO
SACRAMENTO. WE KNOW THE DRIVE
VERY WELL. WE'RE BOTH ALUMNI
FROM UP THE STREET. J STREET
HERE, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, SACRAMENTO, WHERE WE
MET, AND WE HAVE SIX CHILDREN
TOGETHER WHO HAVE DONE VERY WELL
IN PUBLIC EDUCATION. THEY'RE ALL
OUT THERE WORKING HEAVY
EQUIPMENT OPERATORS AND ONE WHO
JUST BECAME A LICENSED
CHIROPRACTOR AND ONE PUBLIC
POLICY GRADUATE FROM BERKELEY.
SO WE'RE WE'RE PRODUCTS OF THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM ALSO
ALSO. AND I GOT AN EARLIER
QUESTION WITH SENATOR LAIRD
ABOUT WHAT MOTIVATES US TO DO
THIS TYPE OF WORK. AND I, I
THOUGHT ABOUT ALL THE KIDS UP
NORTH OF WHO ARE STRUGGLING AND
THOSE WHO HAVE BENEFITED FROM
EDUCATION HAVE SEEN THE POWER OF
EDUCATION AND MEMBERS OF MY OWN
FAMILY AND MYSELF AND WANT TO
SEE THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP CLOSE.
ALSO AND WANT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE BY SERVING ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND
I'VE ENJOYED THE SERVICE TO THE
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
BEING A REP FROM WAY UP NORTH
FOR ONCE, WAY UP IN THE LAST
COUNTY OF CALIFORNIA ON THE
NORTH COAST, UP IN CRESCENT
CITY. THAT'S WHERE I'M FROM. BUT
THANK YOU, MR. MAYOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE KIDS. BUT IN
PARTICULAR YOUR WORK WITH THE
YUROK TRIBE. THANK YOU. WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL. AND YOU BRING
SUCH A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE TO THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND WE ARE
SO APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE LOOKING AT BOARD MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. MADAM BOARD MEMBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE.
MY NAME IS ADRIN RODRIGUEZ AND
I'M A NATIONAL BOARD CERTIFIED
TEACHER. I TEACH AT A HIGH
SCHOOL IN EL CENTRO, CALIFORNIA,
AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
MY STUDENTS AND MY COLLEAGUES
COULDN'T BE HERE, BUT THEY ARE
WATCHING LIVE. SO. HELLO
SPARTANS. THANK YOU. AND I ALSO
HAVE, THE MAYOR OF CITY OF
IMPERIAL, DENNIS MORITA, WHO I'D
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IS ALSO
WATCHING AND A FEW OTHER PEOPLE
WHO SAID THEY WOULD BE TUNING IN
FAMILY MEMBERS, AND I WANT TO
ECHO THE GRATITUDE TO THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE FOR HOSTING US
TODAY. AND GRATITUDE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND STAFF, I'M
VERY GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM
FOR BELIEVING THAT, I WOULD BE A
GOOD REPRESENTATIVE ON THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION, AND
ESPECIALLY HAVING THE TEACHER
VOICE, SITTING IN THIS MEMBER
BODY THAT TELLS US THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE GET TO WE GET TO TALK
ABOUT WHERE THE POLICIES LAND,
RIGHT IN THE CLASSROOM AND HOW
THEY AFFECT OUR STUDENTS. AND SO
THAT IS A VERY UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE. SO ALSO THE WHAT
MOTIVATES ME. IN 2011, I WAS IN
A I HAD A NEAR-DEATH EXPERIENCE.
I WAS HIT BY A SEMI, WE WERE
T-BONED. AND BECAUSE I LIVE IN A
VERY REMOTE REGION IN IMPERIAL
COUNTY, WE DON'T TALK ABOUT
SALTON SEA, I LIVE IN, IN PEARL
COUNTY, AND I HAD TO BE
HELICOPTERED TO PALM SPRINGS,
UNCONSCIOUS. AND I WAS IN A COMA
FOR A MONTH. AND WHEN I CAME OUT
OF THE COMA, MY SURGEON, WHO
SAVED MY LIFE SAID, SO YOU'RE
THE TEACHER. AND I DIDN'T KNOW I
WAS ALL TUBED UP. I DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT. AND
HE SAID, THIS IS PALM SPRINGS.
WE HAVE CELEBRITIES WHO COME
HERE. WE HAD 4000 CALLS. THE
FIRST TWO DAYS. WE HAD TO ASK
PEOPLE TO STOP CALLING. AND I
WAS TEACHING THEATER AT THE
TIME. SO I KNOW THAT SOME OF MY
STUDENTS DISGUISED THEIR VOICE.
SO MAYBE THAT NO. 100. BUT I AND
I REMEMBER LYING THERE IN BED,
AND THEN I LOOKED AROUND AND ALL
THE POSTERS, ALL THE RAPPER
NAMES MY STUDENTS HAD GIVEN ME
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS. AND
FRISELL WAS THE MOST POPULAR
ONE, AND I THOUGHT, WOW, DID I
MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION TO BE A
TEACHER? RIGHT? TO HAVE ACCESS
TO YOUNG MINDS IS JUST AN
INCREDIBLE PRIVILEGE TO WATCH
THE TRANSFORMATION THAT MY
COLLEAGUE TALKED ABOUT, AND TO
SEE THAT DAY IN AND DAY OUT AND
NOW TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL. RIGHT. YOU
KNOW, THE CLASSROOMS, THE
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS JUST A TREMENDOUS
PRIVILEGE. AND THAT IS WHAT
MOTIVATES ME. IN ADDITION TO THE
FACT THAT I DROPPED OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL, I DIDN'T I DIDN'T FEEL
THAT I DIDN'T LIKE MY REBELLIOUS
SIDE. AND I COME FROM A FAMILY
OF EDUCATORS. SO IT WAS NOT IT
DIDN'T FALL WELL, BUT THERE THE
MULTIPLE MEASURES THAT WE TALK
ABOUT TODAY AND DIFFERENT WAYS
OF DEMONSTRATING WHAT WE KNOW,
WHAT OUR STUDENTS KNOW IS VERY
POWERFUL. AND WHEN I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL, THERE WAS ONLY ONE WAY.
THERE WAS ONLY ONE RIGHT ANSWER.
AND I, I LIKE THAT OUR STATE AND
I WANT TO CONTINUE THIS WORK IS
ABLE TO GIVE OUR STUDENTS
MULTIPLE ABILITIES TO
DEMONSTRATE THEIR KNOWLEDGE,
THEIR MASTERY. AND I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE THAT WORK. THANK YOU.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL AND WE ARE
GOING TO START CALLING YOU BOARD
MEMBER RUSSELL. ALL RIGHT. YOU
SEE THERE WE GO. THAT WAS A THAT
WAS A WONDERFUL STORY. AND THE
IMPACT THAT TEACHERS HAVE ON THE
LIVES OF PEOPLE. RIGHT. THANK
YOU. AND JUST SO APPRECIATE YOU
SHARING THAT. AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR STEPPING UP TO SERVE.
WE'RE SO APPRECIATIVE THAT
YOU'RE HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO OPEN IT UP TO THE COMMITTEE,
TO BE ABLE TO SEEK ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS. SENATOR
LAIRD ON THE SALTON SEA, PLEASE,
WE HAVE TO ADJOURN BY FIVE, SO I
WILL NOT BE SPEAKING ABOUT THE
SALTON SEA, LET ME THANK ALL
THREE OF YOU FOR MEETING WITH
ME. AND TWO OF YOU JUST JUMPED
THE GUN A LITTLE. BUT LET ME TRY
ANYWAY. AND START WITH WITH
MEMBER BROWNSON. BECAUSE I
REALIZED WHEN YOU LEFT MY OFFICE
THAT I WAS REALLY MOVED BY EACH
OF YOU TALKING ABOUT WHAT YOUR
MOTIVATION WAS, AND ALSO HOW YOU
WOULD TAKE YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE
AND TURN IT INTO ACTION AT THE
BOARD. AND SO, I'LL PUT THAT TO
MEMBER BROWNSON AND THEN LET THE
OTHER TWO ADD IF THEY THINK
THEIR PREVIOUS ANSWER WASN'T
ENOUGH. SURE SO I THINK, TWO OF
THE THEMES THAT I NAMED AT THE
BEGINNING WERE AROUND STRONG
BEGINNINGS OR STRONG
FOUNDATIONS, AND ALSO OF
ADDRESSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP,
IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS,
WITH BOTH THE ADVENT OF
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN, BUT
ALSO, I THINK A BOLSTERING OF
THE SORT OF PRESCHOOL TO THIRD
GRADE TRAJECTORY THE STATE HAS
AN INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY TO
ACTUALLY GET THE GROUND LAID SO
SOLIDLY SO THAT WE COULD REALLY
I THINK, TRANSFORM K THROUGH 12.
THE STUDY THAT I HAD SHARED IN
OUR CONVERSATION WITH SENATOR
LAIRD EARLIER IS WHEN YOU LOOK
AT CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERFORMANCE
ON A GRADE BY GRADE GROWTH
LEVEL. CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY DOES
SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN THE REST OF
THE NATION ON YEAR TO YEAR
GROWTH FROM EACH GRADE. BUT
WHERE WE ARE MOST CHALLENGED IS
THAT IN THE VERY FIRST YEAR OF
TESTING, IN THIRD GRADE,
CALIFORNIA KIDS START SO MUCH
BEHIND THE EIGHT BALL THAT
THERE'S JUST NOT ENOUGH TIME TO
ACTUALLY MAKE UP THAT
DIFFERENTIAL OF FOUNDATIONS THAT
HAVE NOT YET BEEN BUILT. AND SO
PARTICULARLY AS I THINK ABOUT
WHAT CAN BE DONE IN THIS NEXT
TERM, WITH THE STATE BOARD
CONTINUING TO BUILD THAT STRONG
FOUNDATION OF 2 TO 3 IS A PLACE
WHERE, THE STATE IS ALREADY BEEN
MAKING MASSIVE AND REALLY
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENTS, BOTH
IN TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN, IN
THE LITERACY ROADMAP, IN
LITERACY COACHES. AND THESE ARE
ALL INVESTMENTS THAT PROPERLY
SORT OF BROUGHT TO BEAR AT THE
SCHOOL LEVEL, COULD TRANSFORM
THE FOUNDATIONS THAT KIDS RELY
ON FOR THE REST OF THEIR K TO 12
CAREER. AND THAT IS A REALLY, I
THINK, EXCITING MOMENT, A
PROMISING MOMENT, AND ONE THAT
THAT I'M HOPING WE CAN LEAN INTO
IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS.
THANK YOU. MEMBER MCMILLAN, DO
YOU HAVE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
ADD? WELL, HARD TO FOLLOW THAT,
BUT, I THINK OF MY OWN
EXPERIENCE AND HOW THAT PLAYS
OUT IN MY ROLE IN THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND I'M
THINKING OF THE NEW ETHNIC
STUDIES GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THAT'S GOING
TO BE IMPLEMENTED VERY SOON. AND
HOW, RICH OUR CULTURES ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND DIVERSE AND UP
NORTH. THE KIDS CALL THIS THING
SUCCESS IN BOTH WORLDS. THE
AMERICAN INDIAN KIDS THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO NECESSARILY GIVE
UP YOUR OWN CULTURE IN ORDER TO
BE SUCCESSFUL IN TODAY'S WORLD.
AND I THINK IT'S A WONDERFUL
MESSAGE THAT NATIVE KIDS HAVE UP
THERE FOR ALL, ALL CULTURES THAT
YOU CAN RETAIN YOUR OWN CULTURE.
WE HAVE OUR LANGUAGE OFFERED IN
THE FOUR MAJOR DISTRICTS UP
THERE SCHOOL DISTRICT, OUR
NATIVE LANGUAGE, AND IT'S
ARTICULATED TO MEET THE ENTRY
INTO CSU AND THE UC SYSTEM. AND
THERE'S A WAY NOW OUR GRADUATION
RATES ARE GOING UP FOR AMERICAN
INDIAN KIDS UP NORTH. AND KIDS
DON'T NO LONGER HAVE TO FEEL
THAT THEY HAVE TO GIVE UP ONE IN
ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
TODAY'S WORLD. AND I THINK IT'S
A GREAT, GOAL FOR ALL OF THE
CULTURES. AND I THINK OF THE
STATEWIDE MODEL CURRICULUM
PROJECTS THAT ARE MOVING FORWARD
TO SUPPORT THE ETHNIC STUDIES
AND HOW THAT CAN PLAY OUT
THROUGHOUT SO MANY CULTURES, AND
HOW DIVERSE OUR STATE IS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
YES, THANK YOU. SO AS I
MENTIONED, I DROPPED OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL AND I WOULD DO NOT WANT
ANYBODY TO GO THROUGH THE PAIN
THAT I WENT THROUGH BY MAKING
THAT, SHORT SIGHTED, REBELLIOUS
DECISION. ONE OF THE ADVANTAGES
THAT I HAD IS THAT I CAME FROM A
FAMILY OF EDUCATORS, AND I WAS
IN A COLLEGE PREP SCHOOL, SO I
KNEW I MEAN, I DIDN'T KNOW I
WENT THROUGH A COUPLE OF YEARS
OF DEPRESSION, BUT EVENTUALLY I
DID GET BACK AND WAS ABLE TO
CONTINUE AND GO TO COLLEGE AND
STUDY. I WANT TO PREVENT THAT
PAIN FOR OTHER STUDENTS, AND I
WANT WHEN WE LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
THE CTE PROGRAMS, FOR EXAMPLE,
THAT WE OFFER AT OUR SCHOOLS, I
WATCH STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T FEEL
LIKE THEY HAD A PURPOSE IN
SCHOOL, AND THEY'RE WALKING
AROUND TALLER THERE. MISS
RODRIGUEZ, I'M IN THE, YOU KNOW,
I BUILT THAT PERGOLA, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S LIKE RIGHT OUTSIDE OF MY
CLASSROOM. AND THEY'RE JUST SO
PROUD. AND THEY'RE, THEY HAVE
PLANS FOR WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
DO, WHETHER IT'S WITH MUSIC,
THEATER, YOU KNOW, WE OFFER A
LOT OF A LOT OF CTE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR STUDENTS.
AND SO MAKING DECISIONS AND
SITTING WITH MEMBER MCMILLAN ON
THE JACK, THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE, JOINT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE, I, I FORGOT WHAT THE
P WAS FOR PREPARATION. RIGHT.
AND WE MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT CTE
AND OFFERING PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE EVEN YOUNGER.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE HIGH
SCHOOL, BUT WHERE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY USING WHAT WE SPOKE
ABOUT WITH THE EXPERIENTIAL
LEARNING, WHERE THEY'RE NOT JUST
TELLING US WHAT THEY KNOW, BUT
THEY'RE SHOWING US WHAT THEY CAN
DO WITH WHAT THEY KNOW, THAT'S
VERY VALUABLE FOR ME BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S PURPOSE THAT, WE,
BUILD INTO OUR, OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE'S, LIVES BY PROVIDING
THESE OPPORTUNITIES AND SO THAT
IS, YOU KNOW, WHEN, WHEN I MAKE
DECISIONS ON THE STATE BOARD, I
THINK ABOUT MY OWN EXPERIENCES
AND THE HIGH SCHOOLS THAT I
WOULD HAVE LOVED, SO THAT THERE
ARE ENOUGH SPOKES LIKE THE
SPOKES OF A WHEEL IN PLACE SO A
CHILD DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE A BAD
DECISION, AND THINKING ABOUT,
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, YOU KNOW, THE
MULTIPLE MEASURES THAT WE HAVE
FOR SCHOOLS TO SHOW US, RIGHT?
ARE THEY DOING WELL ON TESTS? DO
WE HAVE COMMUNITY PARTICIPATION,
WITH WITH THE LCAP MODEL? HOW
ARE THEY, WHAT'S THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE? RIGHT. YOU KNOW, AND
TEACHERS, WE CAN DO THAT FOR OUR
STUDENTS AS WELL. RIGHT. GIVE
THEM MULTIPLE MEASURES TO SHOW
US WHAT THEY KNOW, TO CREATE
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THERE'S A
VARIETY HAPPENING. AND I'M
EXCITED TO BE PART OF THIS, THIS
CHANGE, THIS TRANSFORMATION IN
EDUCATION. OUR CURRENT STATE
BOARD. I REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE. AND IT OCCURS TO ME
AND MAYBE IT'S PRURIENT
INTEREST. DO YOU HAVE YOU
ENCOUNTERED STUDENTS IN YOUR OWN
CLASSES THAT WERE REBELLIOUS THE
WAY YOU THOUGHT YOU WERE
REBELLIOUS IN HIGH SCHOOL, AND
HOW DOES THAT ALLOW YOU? DO YOU
HAVE A WAY TO REACH THEM IN A
WAY YOU THOUGHT YOU WEREN'T
REACHABLE WHEN THAT HAPPENED?
ABSOLUTELY. I JUST DON'T GIVE
THEM ANYTHING TO REBEL AGAINST,
BECAUSE IF I WANT TO BE IN YOUR
CLASS, RIGHT. YOU KNOW, IF THEY.
IF THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
SOMETHING TO REBEL, THEY WILL.
AND SO AND IT, YOU KNOW, MANY OF
OVER A THOUSAND YEARS AGO, SAINT
AUGUSTINE SAID THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR A STUDENT TO
KNOW THAT YOU LOVE THEM. AND
WHILE THAT'S, YOU KNOW, A VERY
GENERAL, GENERAL WORD AND
CONCEPT, BUT MY STUDENTS KNOW
WHEN THEY WALK INTO MY CLASSROOM
THAT THEY'RE WELCOME THERE, THAT
THEY'RE ACCEPTED AND THAT THEY
IF THEY'RE IF THEY WANT TO PUSH,
WHICH IS A VERY NATURAL ASPECT
OF ADOLESCENCE. RIGHT? IF THEY
WANT TO PUSH THE ENVELOPE, THERE
WILL BE A CONSEQUENCE BUT NOT
PUNISHMENT. AND SO THEY JUST,
YOU KNOW, THEY THEY KNOW THAT
WHAT I'M WHAT WHAT I'M PROPOSING
TO THEM IS FOR THEIR OWN GOOD.
THEY KNOW THAT. THAT'S
IMPRESSIVE. WELL, THANK YOU. ALL
THREE OF YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE. I
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU. THE
RESPONSE THANK YOU, SENATOR
LAIRD. SENATOR EGGMAN, DID YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS, THESE ARE THREE
REAPPOINTMENTS TO THREE VERY
CLEARLY QUALIFIED PEOPLE, AND I
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SERVICE. THANK YOU FOR
INSPIRATION FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MA'AM. SENATOR JONES,
DID YOU HAVE QUESTIONS? YEAH,
JUST A QUICK, ONE THAT MAYBE
EACH PERSON CAN ADDRESS. I'VE
GOT IN MY NOTES FROM SOME OF THE
RESEARCH AND THEN IT REMINDED
ME, I'VE HEARD FROM A COUPLE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS AND SOME
ADMINISTRATORS AND SOME PARENTS
THAT ARE CONCERNED ABOUT. I
GUESS I'LL USE THEIR TERM, THE
NEW MATH THAT THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION PASSED LAST YEAR, AND
IT SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN NOT IT
SEEMS TO BE NOT WORKING OUT VERY
WELL. MY UNDERSTANDING IS A
UNANIMOUS VOTE BY THE BOARD, AND
I JUST WONDERED IF YOU HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THAT. IS IT WORKING
OUT THE WAY YOU EXPECTED? IS IT
A DISASTER, YOU KNOW, WHAT ARE
YOUR YOU KNOW, IF THERE WAS MY
UNDERSTANDING, THERE WASN'T A
VERY ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS WHEN IT CAME UP AS ROBUST
AS MANY OF OUR SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WOULD HAVE HOPED
FOR. SO I WAS JUST WONDERING IF
YOU COULD SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE
AND IF I NEED TO GET YOU SOME
MORE INFORMATION. I'LL TRY TO
SPIN THROUGH MY NOTES HERE REAL
QUICK AND TRY TO GET IT. IF YOU
NEED IT, I CAN START. IT WAS THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WE PASSED LAST
YEAR, AND WE'RE MOVING INTO THE
PROCESS. SO WE'RE SELECTION OF
MATERIALS WILL TAKE PLACE NEXT
OF, WORK GROUP OUT THERE
EXPLORING DIFFERENT MATERIALS
THAT WILL BE USED FOR THE
FRAMEWORK. MY UNDERSTANDING OF
THE FRAMEWORK IS IT'S, IT'S MUCH
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF BUILDING
THE BACKGROUND FOR STUDENTS SO
THAT THEY KNOW HOW MATHEMATICS
AFFECTS, AFFECTS THEM IN
EVERYDAY LIFE BEFORE THEY PLUNGE
IN AND TALK ABOUT ALGORITHMS AND
OTHER PARTS OF IT. AND SO THAT
THEY CAN BE MORE TURNED ON TO
MATH RATHER THAN TURNED OFF
BUILDING THAT BACKGROUND, IT, IT
HAS A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHERE, LEAS CAN
DEVELOP THEIR SEQUENCE WITHIN
THEIR OWN PARAMETERS LOCALLY,
STUDENTS, CAN BE ENCOURAGED TO
ACCELERATE IF THEY'RE READY TO.
IT MEETS THE STUDENTS AT THEIR
LEVEL THAT FRAMEWORK, AND THEY
CAN ACCELERATE OR IF THEY NEED
EXTRA SUPPORTS IT, IT BUILDS
THOSE SUPPORTS AROUND THEM,
WHETHER THEY NEED EXTRA HELP
AFTER SCHOOL OR BEFORE SCHOOL OR
TUTORING IT. IT ALLOWS FOR THAT,
AND THEN POSSIBLY IF THERE ARE
BARRIERS, SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
BARRIERS WITH, WITH ALL THE
SUPPORT SYSTEMS TRYING TO REMOVE
THOSE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL BARRIERS
SO THEY CAN LEARN. SO THAT'S ALL
IN THE FRAMEWORK. SO THANK YOU,
ONE OF THE EARLY PRESENTATIONS
ON THE MATH FRAMEWORK THAT I
REMEMBER, PARTICULARLY RELATED
TO THE IDEAS PRESENTED IN EARLY
MATH IS THAT, IN IN A RECENT
POLL, TOP TWO PHOBIAS NAMED BY
AMERICANS ACROSS THE BOARD IS
PUBLIC SPEAKING AND MATH, AND SO
I THINK A LOT OF THE MATH
FRAMEWORK IS REALLY AIMED AT
CREATING DIFFERENT POINTS OF
ENTRY TO MAKE SOMETHING THAT'S
VITAL AND NECESSARY FOR KIDS TO
LEARN, BUT TO MAKE IT MORE
APPROACHABLE TO, WORK WITH WORD
PROBLEMS MORE. FOR EXAMPLE, THAT
IS MUCH MORE PRACTICAL
APPLICATION RATHER THAN JUST
SORT OF MORE ABSTRACT CONCEPTS.
RIGHT AWAY, AND TO, TO A BOARD
MEMBER. MCQUILLAN'S COMMENTS
EARLIER, THIS IDEA OF MEETING OR
MEETING STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE,
RATHER THAN HAVING A SET
TRAJECTORY OF IN THIS GRADE,
THIS STUDENT SHALL TAKE THIS
COURSE AND THERE IS NO
FLEXIBILITY, BUT INSTEAD TO
PRESERVE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT
LOCAL SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
MATH TEACHERS CAN ACTUALLY HELP
A STUDENT NAVIGATE, WHAT CONTENT
THEY'RE READY FOR. AND WHEN,
THERE'S A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AROUND. AND WE HAD A LOT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT AROUND WHAT GRADE
ALGEBRA BEGINS IN, AND THAT, BY
THE WAY, IS ONE WHERE WE
PRESERVE THE OPTION, TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE ALGEBRA IN EIGHTH GRADE
IF A STUDENT IS READY TO HAVE
ACCELERATION PATHWAYS LATER INTO
HIGH SCHOOL, IF THAT IS MORE
APPROPRIATE, AND IF I COULD SAY
AND THANK YOU FOR THAT, THE AND
I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHEN
I WAS TEACHING AVID AND AVID. WE
HAVE WHAT ARE CALLED TUTORIALS.
SO THE STUDENTS BRING IN
SOMETHING THAT THEY'RE
STRUGGLING WITH. THEY SIT IN THE
GROUP AND THEY ASK QUESTIONS TO
HELP GUIDE THEM TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEMS. RIGHT. AND WE HAVE
TUTORS, BUT THE TUTORS DON'T
GIVE THEM THE ANSWERS. SO THEY
ASK THEM, WHAT DO YOU THINK THIS
LOOKS LIKE? HOW SHOULD THIS
LOOK? SO I HAD A STUDENT WHO
CAME IN ONE DAY AND SHE'S LIKE,
MR. RODRIGUEZ, IS IT OKAY IF I
DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
TUTORIAL? AND I SAID, WHY?
WHAT'S GOING ON? AND SHE'S LIKE,
I'M STRUGGLING WITH EQUATIONS
AND I JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE
MATH RIGHT NOW. AND I SAID,
WELL, OKAY, BUT MAYBE YOU I'M
GOING TO HAVE YOU HELP ME WITH
SOMETHING. I'M PLANNING A PARTY
AND I NEED SOME HELP. SO I TOLD
HER AND SHE'S LIKE, WELL, HOW
MUCH ARE YOU GOING TO SPEND? I
KNEW SHE WAS REALLY GOOD AT
PARTY PLANNING. AND SO I TOLD
HER, X AMOUNT OF MONEY. RIGHT.
AND SO SHE WROTE IT DOWN AND I'M
GOING TO HAVE THIS. AND HOW MUCH
IS THIS GOING TO COST? AND SO
ANYWAY, WHEN WE WERE DONE, SHE,
I TOLD HER, OH, I'M GOING TO
INVITE THIS MANY PEOPLE. SHE'S
LIKE, NO, YOU CAN'T. BECAUSE
THIS AND THE FOOD. SO BEFORE I
KNEW IT, SHE WAS I SAID, OKAY,
THANK YOU. I'M REALLY NOT HAVING
A PARTY, BUT YOU JUST USED
EQUATIONS IN ALL OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT YOU SOLVED. AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHEN I VOTED FOR THE NEW
MATH FRAMEWORK. THAT'S WHAT I
THOUGHT ABOUT, RIGHT? GIVING
STUDENTS DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO USE THE MATHEMATICAL BRAIN
THAT WE ALL HAVE. I THINK WE
WERE ALL BORN WITH THE
MATHEMATICAL BRAIN TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS. AND SO WHEN STUDENTS
ARE GIVEN PROBLEMS, ESPECIALLY
AS THEIR BRAINS ARE GROWING AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE PRUNING IN
ADOLESCENCE, THEY BECOME PROBLEM
SOLVERS AND THEY DON'T FEEL THAT
FEAR OF MATH. RIGHT. BECAUSE, IT
JUST, YOU KNOW, I TELL THEM THE
NUMBERS AREN'T GOING TO JUMP OUT
AND, YOU KNOW, START LIKE
SCRATCHING YOU. THEY'RE THEY'RE
JUST NUMBERS. BUT THAT FEAR IS
VERY REAL, THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES, SENATOR MCGUIRE DID HAVE
TO STEP OUT AS SENATE PRO TEM
AND CHAIR OF RULES, AND HE HAS A
BIG PLATE AND HE ASKED FOR HIS
FORGIVENESS. AND HE WILL BE BACK
AS SOON AS HE POSSIBLY CAN, YOU
GUYS MENTIONED CTE JUST FOR
EVERYBODY WATCHING ONLINE THAT
DON'T FOLLOW EDUCATION AS MUCH
AS ALL OF US DO. CAREER,
TECHNICAL EDUCATION, CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION WAS TAKEN
OUT OF THE SCHOOL SYSTEM FOR
QUITE A LONG PERIOD OF TIME,
WHERE WE THREW EVERY KID ON AN
AVENUE TO COLLEGE. EXCUSE ME, I,
LIKE YOU, AM A HIGH SCHOOL
DROPOUT AND I'M ONE OF 40. GO
FIGURE. SO, I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS, IS THAT ARE YOU GUYS
PROMOTING CTE ON A REGULAR
BASIS? AND THERE'S OTHER AVENUES
BECAUSE NOT EVERY KID IS GOING
TO GO TO COLLEGE. WE NEED
MECHANICS. IF THEY LIKE MECHANIC
WORK, WE LIKE THE KIDS THAT LIKE
TO WORK WITH THEIR TOOLS. I
MEAN, I LOOK AT MY 11 GRANDKIDS,
I'VE GOT ONE THAT WANTS TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT MOUNT VESUVIUS AND
HOW TORNADOES START. AND THE,
YOU KNOW, IS THE EARTH'S CORE
REALLY THIS. AND THEN I'VE GOT
ONE THAT'S LIKE, YOU KNOW, HE
COULD CARE LESS. SO I THINK
EVERY KID IS DIFFERENT. AND SO
I'M JUST ASKING ABOUT YOUR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
FOUNDATION IN THE SCHOOLS AND
WHAT YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS ARE,
MR. JOHNSON. SURE. OH, SIR. GO
RIGHT AHEAD, I RECENTLY BEGAN TO
CHAIR THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION THAT WE
HAVE. IT'S A JOINT ADVISORY
BETWEEN THE STATE BOARD AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, BOARD
MEMBERS. AND THE STATE HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION. AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT. AND SEE
THAT NOT EVERYONE NEEDS TO GO TO
COLLEGE OR WILL GO TO COLLEGE.
WE NEED WE NEED THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE GOING TO WORK ON OUR
ELECTRIC CARS, WHO ARE BEYOND
JUST PLUMBERS AND WOODWORKERS.
IT'S VERY TECHNICAL. THOSE
HEALTH PROFESSIONS, WHEN OUR
COMPUTERS GO DOWN, WHO'S GOING
TO FIX THOSE COMPUTERS? WHO DO
WE CALL? AND THOSE ARE THE FOLKS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, THOSE
JOBS FOR THE FUTURE. YOU KNOW,
AND MANY OF THEM, WE CAN'T EVEN
VISUALIZE WHAT THEY ARE YET
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE DOWN THE
ROAD FOR THAT NEXT GENERATION.
SO WE NEED TO BE READY. THERE
ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT JOBS OUT
THERE THAT REQUIRE THAT
TECHNICAL HANDS ON, YOU KNOW, IN
MY INTRODUCTION, I HAVE A
DAUGHTER WHO JUST BECAME
LICENSED AS A CHIROPRACTOR, AND
SHE'S VERY BUSY. SHE'LL SEE 40
PEOPLE IN A DAY. THAT'S THAT'S
THE SAME AREA, YOU KNOW, THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US ALL FOR THOSE
POSITIONS. AND THEY'RE NOT,
TYPICALLY A FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
DEGREES. THEY'RE FOLKS WHO ARE
READY TO GO TO WORK. AND IN A
YEAR OR A COUPLE OF YEARS OF
TRAINING. SO VERY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU. EITHER. YES. AND I
SERVE WITH MEMBER MCQUILLAN ON,
ON THE COMMITTEE. AND THANK YOU
FOR CLARIFYING CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION, I THINK THAT
SOMETIMES WE USE SO MANY
ACRONYMS, YES. IT'S EXACTLY I,
WE HAVE, HAVE MADE A HUGE
INVESTMENT AND DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THE, THE PATHWAYS. WE
HAVE ALSO FOUND THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO ATTENDANCE, STUDENTS IN
HIGH SCHOOLS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN CAREER PATHWAYS
TEND TO HAVE BETTER ATTENDANCE,
RIGHT. AND THAT SAYS THAT GOES
BACK TO PURPOSE. THEY FEEL LIKE
THEIR WORKING TOWARDS SOMETHING,
WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
PARTNERSHIPS AND THERE OF
COURSE, TAILORED TOWARD
COMMUNITY NEEDS. RIGHT. I'M FROM
A VERY SIMILAR, AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY LIKE BAKERSFIELD. AND
SO WE HAVE CERTAIN NEEDS THAT
PERHAPS THEY DON'T HAVE IN LOS
ANGELES. AND SO WE FIND THE
PROFESSIONALS TO COME IN AND
WORK WITH OUR STUDENTS AND
MODEL. AND THERE'S SOMETHING
VERY POWERFUL ABOUT MENTORSHIP.
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU, THE NEXT
QUESTION I HAVE IS, IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, I'M ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
THAT THINKS THAT EVERY PARENT
PAYS TAXES, WHETHER YOU'RE A
PARENT AND HAVE A KID IN SCHOOL
OR A GRANDPARENT OR YOU HAVE NO
CHILDREN IN SCHOOL, YOU STILL
PAY TAXES FOR THE EDUCATION
THAT'S PROVIDED TO, IT
OBVIOUSLY, THE CONSTITUTION SAYS
THAT, CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
SAYS THAT EVERY CHILD IS
ENTITLED TO A FREE PUBLIC
EDUCATION, BUT IT DOESN'T SAY
YOU HAVE TO BE IN A PUBLIC
BUILDING, THAT'S VERY CLEAR, I'M
INTERESTED TO KNOW YOUR POSITION
ON SCHOOL CHOICE, SPECIFICALLY
CHARTER SCHOOLS, BUT ALSO MONEY.
FOLLOWING THE STUDENT, BECAUSE
THERE ARE A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT
GET LEFT BEHIND IN OUR
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS THAT
MAY NEED. AND LET'S JUST BE
HONEST, I LOVE TEACHERS AND I
THINK TEACHERS ARE GREAT, BUT
THERE'S NOT A TEACHER LIKE YOU
IN EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL, THERE'S
A KID. IF A KID COMES TO SOME
TEACHERS AND SAYS, I'M NOT, I
DON'T REALLY WANT TO DO
EQUATIONS TODAY. WELL, TOO BAD
YOU'RE GOING TO DO EQUATIONS.
AND THEN THERE'S A DEFIANCE OR
REBELLION, WHATEVER HAPPENS,
RIGHT. THAT THAT IS A THAT'S A
MORE OF THE STUFF THAT I GET
COMING INTO MY OFFICE THAN, THAN
THE EXEMPLARY TEACHER THAT YOU
HAVE DESCRIBED ABOUT HOW YOU
HANDLE STUDENTS. SO I'M
INTERESTED IN YOUR OPINION ON
SCHOOL CHOICE AND WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE TO YOU IF YOU ARE
INTERESTED OR YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
IT. MR. RODRIGUEZ, LET ME START
WITH YOU. SURE. THANK YOU, I
APOLOGIZE. OH, NO, THAT'S FINE,
YES. ACTUALLY WHEN? IN 2001, I
WAS A ONE OF TEN TEACHERS THAT
FOUNDED A CHARTER SCHOOL IN EAST
PALO ALTO AND I BELIEVE THAT
SOMETIMES IT'S NECESSARY. THERE
WASN'T A PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN
EAST PALO ALTO, SO STUDENTS WERE
WERE BEING SENT OFF UP TO 30
MILES FROM THEIR HOMES TO GO TO
SCHOOL. RIGHT. SO THAT'S WHY WE
STARTED THAT PARTICULAR SCHOOL.
AND IT'S THRIVING TODAY, I'M
HAPPY TO SAY. AND THAT GAVE THAT
GAVE THE PARENTS IN THAT
COMMUNITY THE CHOICE, THE
NECESSARY CHOICE TO BE ABLE TO
BE, ON TOP OF YOU KNOW, GOING
ON, GOING TO VISIT THE SCHOOL,
BEING ABLE TO KNOW HOW THEIR
STUDENTS WERE DOING, THEIR
CHILDREN WERE DOING, KNOWING THE
TEACHERS, WHICH IS A LOT HARDER
WHEN THEY'RE BEING BUSED OUT. SO
FAR AWAY. AND NOT ALL STUDENTS
LEARN THE SAME. AND SO SOMETIMES
THERE ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
TAILORED, FOR PARTICULAR STUDENT
NEEDS OR CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
RIGHT. AND THAT'S, AND, AND I'VE
SEEN IN MY YEARS SOME WONDERFUL
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND LIKE PUBLIC
EDUCATION, LIKE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, ACCOUNTABILITY
IS ALWAYS NECESSARY. RIGHT.
BECAUSE LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S
PUBLIC FUNDS. AND SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT, ALL STUDENTS
ARE WELCOME, THAT THEY'RE ALL
HAVING THEIR NEEDS MET, THAT
THEY'RE FOLLOWING THE SAME
GUIDELINES THAT THE STATE HAS
ESTABLISHED FOR ALL OTHER PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
NO, I'M THINKING ABOUT UP NORTH
ALL THE OPTIONS WE HAVE WITHIN
OUR EXISTING PUBLIC SYSTEM. NOT
AS MANY OPTIONS AS SOME OF THE
URBAN AREAS, BUT THERE ARE
THERE'S MAGNET TYPE PROGRAMS
WITHIN THE DISTRICTS UP THERE,
OUTDOOR EDUCATION, THERE ARE A
FEW CHARTERS THAT OFFER, OPTIONS
ALSO FOR STUDENTS THAT NEED TO
ACCELERATED LEARNING AND OR WHO,
FOR WHATEVER REASON, NEED
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
OR WHO NEED EXTRA SUPPORT. SOME
OF THE CHARTERS OFFER THAT UP
THERE AND, IT'S PRETTY GOOD
THOUGH, SOME OF THOSE OPTIONS.
THANK YOU, MR. BRANT, MEMBER
BROWNSON YEAH, I, I DEFINITELY
HAVE SEEN. AND SUPPORT THE WIDE
VARIETY OF SCHOOL OPTIONS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO PARENTS AND
CHILDREN IN MY HOME TOWN IN LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED. IT'S ACTUALLY
CALLED THE CHOICES BROCHURE, AND
IT INCLUDES A WHOLE VARIETY OF
BILINGUAL SCHOOLS, OF MAGNET
SCHOOLS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS, OF,
ACTUALLY, WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
APPEALS PREVIOUSLY COME OUR WAY
AROUND INTERNATIONAL
BACCALAUREATE SCHOOLS. AND I
THINK THAT SET OF OPTIONS
ENABLES PARENTS TO EFFECTIVELY
NAVIGATE A SYSTEM AND FIGURE OUT
WHAT THEIR KIDS NEED AND WHERE
THEY CAN BEST BE SERVED, AND WE
HAVE, PARTICULARLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF APPEALS SEEN, A WIDE
VARIETY OF SCHOOLS COME AND
TESTIFY BEFORE THE STATE BOARD.
THANK YOU, JUST TO COMMENT ON ON
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE. AND
I ASKED THAT QUESTION BECAUSE I
HAVE A FRIEND THAT HAS A DOWN
SYNDROME CHILD WHO'S NOT HIGH
FUNCTIONING, BUT MID-LEVEL
FUNCTIONING. AND, ALL OF HER ALL
THE WAY UP TO EIGHTH GRADE OR
FRESHMAN YEAR. SHE WAS TOLD BY
THE PUBLIC, YOU CAN'T, YOU KNOW,
YOUR YOUR KID IS NEVER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS. YOUR
DAUGHTER WILL NEVER BE ABLE TO
DO THIS, WON'T BE ABLE TO DO
THIS. AND THEY FOUND A PRIVATE
SCHOOL COST OF $12,000 A YEAR.
AND IT'S VERY EXPENSIVE. THEY
DON'T GET ANY STATE HELP FOR
THAT. SHE GOES TO THAT SCHOOL,
SHE'S IN DRAMA. SHE'S IN
LANGUAGE ARTS. SHE STARTED
SELLING ART. SHE'S DEVELOPED AN
ART SKILL. SHE AUCTIONS OFF
ARTWORK FOR A LOT OF MONEY. LIKE
SHE RAISES A LOT OF MONEY FOR
VETERANS. $50,000. I THINK THE
LAST PIECE THAT SHE DID ON A
FLAG WAS SOME TREES IN FRONT OF
IT. SHE'S REALLY GIFTED. SHE'S
IN CHEER. SHE PLAYS SOCCER. AND
LIKE I SAID, THE LANGUAGE ARTS
PROGRAM AND HER SPEECH THERAPY
THAT SHE GETS FROM THAT SCHOOL
THAT HER PARENTS HAVE TO PAY FOR
AFTER PAYING TAXES, THE SPEECH
PATHOLOGIST OR THE SPEECH PERSON
THAT'S ASSIGNED TO THAT SCHOOL
HAS REALLY INCREASED HER
VOCABULARY WHERE SHE'S ACTUALLY
VERY WELL, COMMUNICATIVE. SHE
STARTED HER OWN INSTAGRAM PAGE,
AND SO IT'S JUST REALLY A GOOD
SUCCESS STORY, AND I JUST DON'T
KNOW WHY THAT'S NOT OFFERED TO
EVERY STUDENT. YOU HAVE TO BE
WEALTHY TO BE ABLE TO GET YOUR
STUDENT THE RIGHT EDUCATION THAT
YOU WANT THEM TO GO TO, BECAUSE
WE DON'T ALLOW THE MONEY TO
FOLLOW A STUDENT, AND THEN ON
YOUR COMMENT, MISS RODRIGUEZ,
THERE ARE A LOT OF PARENTS WHO
DON'T AGREE WITH WHAT'S GOING ON
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM, AND
THEY WANT AN OPTION. SO FOR YOU
TO SAY THAT THEY CAN HAVE THAT
OPTION AS LONG AS WE FOLLOW
THESE RULES THAT ARE SET BY THE
STATE, I DISAGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT, BUT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS, I CLARIFIED
CTE AND, I THINK THAT'S ALL I
HAD, BUT THANK YOU, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE DAIS? WE'RE
GOOD. WE ARE NOW GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE OR THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD AND
MAKE A STATEMENT IN SUPPORT, IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE COME FORWARD TO
THIS MICROPHONE RIGHT HERE.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND A
BRIEF COMMENTS AND WHERE YOU'RE
FROM OR WHO YOU REPRESENT AND,
AND BRIEF COMMENTS ON YOUR
SUPPORT POSITION. PERFECT ESTARÁ
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT OF ALL
OF THE THREE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION REAPPOINTMENTS FOR KIM
PATTILLO BROWNSON, HEIDI
RODRIGUEZ, AND JAMES MCCLELLAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
MA'AM. WELCOME, SIR. THANK YOU,
MADAM VICE CHAIR MEMBERS TRISTAN
BROWN WITH CAFTA, UNION OF
EDUCATORS AND CLASSIFIED
PROFESSIONALS. WE HAD THE HONOR
TO SPEAK TO EVERY CANDIDATE AND
HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE TO WORK
WITH THEM OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. IN THEIR FIRST
APPOINTMENT, I THINK SENATOR
TALAMANTES EGGMAN SAID IT
PERFECTLY. WE'VE HEARD AMAZING
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY. WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO ANOTHER FOUR
YEARS, SO WE ASK FOR THEIR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR. YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. ALICE KESSLER, I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION, AND
WE ARE ALSO PLEASED TO SUPPORT
ALL THREE OF THE BOARD MEMBERS
IN THEIR CONFIRMATION, REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DIALOG TODAY ON
SCHOOL CHOICE AND CHARTER SCHOOL
ISSUES. AND I JUST THINK THIS
PANEL REPRESENTS GREAT DIVERSITY
IN TERMS OF THEIR EXPERIENCE
WHERE THEY ARE IN THE STATE AND
THE STUDENTS THAT THEY'RE EACH
UPLIFTING. SO I WANTED TO, TO
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THEIR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU.
DIANA, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS, IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF MEMBERS PORTILLO,
BRONSON MCQUILLAN AND RODRIGUEZ.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YES,
MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON, LINDSEY
TORNATORE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF EACH OF THE THREE
APPOINTEES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS IN THE ROOM WITH
SUPPORT, WE'LL GO TO OPPOSITION.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM FOR
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE IN
OPPOSITION. I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS FOR QUESTIONS OR A
MOTION. YES, SENATOR LAIRD, I
WOULD MOVE APPROVAL OF ALL THREE
NOMINEES AND THAT WE FORWARD
THEIR NAMES TO THE SENATE FLOOR
FOR CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. SECRETARY, WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? PARDON ME.
TOGETHER ON ALL THREE TOGETHER?
YES YES, YES. MAGUIRE GROVE NOT
VOTING. GROVE. NOT VOTING.
EGGMAN EGGMAN I JONES. JONES.
NOT VOTING. LAIRD I LAIRD I 2 TO
0 ON CALL. SO WE WILL WAIT FOR
SENATOR MAGUIRE TO COME BACK AND
CAST HIS VOTE. AND KNOWING
SENATOR MAGUIRE, I KNOW THAT HE
WILL PROBABLY BE AN AYE VOTE. I
CAN'T SPEAK FOR HIM, BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR CONFIRMATION ON
THE FLOOR. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. I'M
LOOKING AT OUR COURT REPORTER.
DO YOU NEED A BREAK? NO OKAY, SO
NEXT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP,
MRS. DELBAR, PLEASE COME UP TO
THE TABLE. THESE ARE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES STILL REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. THE ITEM IS ONE D
COLLEAGUES FOR THE APPOINTMENT
OF CATHERINE OR KATIE DEL BAR TO
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION, PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
OPEN. WE'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE OF
MINUTES TO OPEN AND SHARE. IF
YOU HAVE FAMILY OR GUESTS HERE.
AND THEN JUST TELL US A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT YOURSELF AND WHY
YOU'RE SEEKING THIS APPOINTMENT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO MISS SHIN FOR
RETIREMENT AND FOR YOU AS WELL.
I RETIRED AND FOR 33 YEARS WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO
YOU'RE GOING TO REALLY ENJOY IT.
I WANT TO INTRODUCE TODAY MY
HUSBAND, MICHAEL DELBAR, IS WITH
ME IN THE BACK. SO I HAVE SERVED
EIGHT YEARS, SO FAR ON THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY AS THEIR LIVESTOCK
RANGE REPRESENTATIVE DIRECTOR
AND HAVE REALLY ENJOYED THAT. I
COME FROM A BACKGROUND OF, OF
CATTLE AND, AND HAY, AND WE GROW
IN POTTER VALLEY, CALIFORNIA. SO
WITH STRONG ROOTS. MY FAMILY
SETTLED THERE IN 1859. AND WE'RE
STILL THERE, GOING AS STRONG AS
YOU CAN, AS YOU CAN GO, WITH
COSTS AND EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
GOES ON IN AGRICULTURE. SO, WE,
I'M APOLOGIZING. I'M A LITTLE
NERVOUS THIS MORNING. THAT'S
OKAY. SO WE'RE NOBODY TRUST US.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAUGHT ME UP
ON ALL THE EDUCATION. I'M ALSO,
SIT ON THE BOARD OF THE SCHOOL
BOARD IN OUR LITTLE TOWN. AND SO
THAT WAS REALLY INTERESTING,
THANK YOU, WELL. THANK YOU. SO
AFTER I CAME ON THE BOARD IN
2016 AND 2018, OUR RANCH WAS
TAKEN BY THE RANCH FIRE IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND WENT INTO
LAKE COUNTY. AND WE LOST 5000
ACRES. WOW. 1800 ACRES OF TIMBER
THAT JUST, WILL NEVER COME BACK
TO THE WAY IT WAS. AND THEN IT
WAS IT HEADED OUT INTO THE
NATIONAL FOREST, WHERE WE ALSO
HAVE A PERMIT, AND WE LOST 40
HEAD OF CATTLE OUT THERE AND
WORKED IT EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR
ABOUT 45 DAYS TO TRY TO RESCUE
WHAT WE COULD AND, AND BRING
BACK. I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE BY
BEING ON THE BOARD, I'VE SEEN
BOTH SIDES, OF WHAT THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY AND ALSO LANDOWNERS GO
THROUGH. AND I'VE BEEN ON THE
SIDE WITHOUT THE FIRES AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
ON LAND TO MAKE IT RESILIENT.
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ON THE OTHER
SIDE NOW WHERE WE'VE LOST IT
ALL. AND HOW DO YOU, RESTORE AND
BRING BACK WHAT WAS ONCE THERE?
AND, AND BOTH ARE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AS SMALL LANDOWNERS.
SO I FEEL LIKE THAT GIVES ME A
ONE SIDE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK OUT
ON THE BOARD AND HELP AND THE
OTHER SIDE IS TRYING TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT LIVESTOCK PLAYS A
HUGE ROLE IN HELPING CALIFORNIA
FIGHT FIRES. AND I FEEL LIKE
WE'VE KIND OF LOST THAT
PERSPECTIVE ALONG THE WAY. THERE
ONCE WAS A POSTER THAT CAL FIRE
HAD THAT SHOWED CATTLE, AND IT
SAID, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE YOUR
NEIGHBORS THAT HELP PREVENT
WILDFIRES. AND I HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT IN A VERY LONG TIME. AND
I'M SURE IT'S NOT ONE THAT'S
USED ANYMORE, BUT IT'S VERY
TRUE. AND WE COULD REALLY SEE
THAT ON OUR RANCH WHEN IT BURNED
THROUGH. ONE SIDE OF IT WAS
GRAZING. AND THE OTHER SIDE,
WHEN YOU GOT TO THE TOP, YOU HIT
THE TIMBER. AND THE PART THAT
WAS GRAZED WAS SLOWER. WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY HELP BESIDES OUR OWN
FAMILY THAT WERE ON THE RANCH
DURING THE TIME TO HELP PUT IT
OUT. WE SAVED OUR HOME AND WE
SAVED SOME OF THE FENCING AROUND
IT. BUT THAT WAS IT. BUT WHEN IT
HIT THE HIT THE TIMBER, IT
REALLY WENT, AND THE OAK TREES
FLOURISHED WHERE THE FIRE WENT
THROUGH. AND THERE WAS ACTUALLY
SOME REAL NICE BENEFITS FROM
WHAT HAPPENED ON THAT SIDE. BUT
ON THE OTHER SIDE, IT IT
DESTROYED. SO, SO I'M A REAL
ADVOCATE FOR TRYING TO GET
LIVESTOCK BACK OUT ON THE
GROUND, IT NEEDS TO BE MANAGED.
AND IF IT'S DONE PROPERLY, IS
CAN BE A REAL ADVANTAGE TO HELP
FIGHT FIRES IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THANK
YOU FOR THAT TESTIMONY, I WAS
ACTUALLY SITTING ON THIS
COMMITTEE, AND MY HUSBAND SENT
ME A TEXT, AND HE SAYS THERE'S A
FIRE AT THE RANCH. AND BEFORE WE
FINISH THIS COMMITTEE, MY
HUSBAND GOES, COME STRAIGHT TO
THE RANCH. THE RANCH IS ON FIRE.
AND THAT'S A BIG DIFFERENCE IN A
TEXT. AND WE LOST, WE LOST 2600
ACRES. AND IT WAS IN LIVESTOCK.
AND THEN WHEN WE HAD THEIR SKIN
FIRE, WE WERE HAULING HORSE
TRAILERS AND GOING OVER THE
BACKSIDE OF HILLS AND JUST
TRYING TO RESCUE CATTLE, BURNED
HOOVES, RARELY WALKS. CALVES
COULDN'T HARDLY WALK BECAUSE
THEIR HOOVES WERE BURNED OFF. IS
A PRETTY TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE.
SO I TOTALLY GET WHERE YOU'RE
COMING FROM. I GET THE GRAZING
PIECE, I REALLY DO. I GET THE
GRAZING PIECE. I THINK, CATTLE
MITIGATION AND GRAZING CREATES A
VERY SAFE ENVIRONMENT ON
MITIGATING, FUEL FOR FIRES IN
THE FUTURE, ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
GRASS IS GREEN. IT PROVIDES FEED
AND WHEN IT'S BROWN WE EAT OFF
SOME OF IT, BUT AT LEAST IT
MITIGATES THE WILDFIRE SITUATION
THAT WE HAVE. SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING SOMEBODY WITH
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE TO BE
APPOINTED TO THIS COMMITTEE BY
THE GOVERNOR AND THAT'S I
SHOULDN'T HAVE COMMENTED. FIRST,
I APOLOGIZE, BUT I CAN COME BACK
TO THE DAIS, DOES ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS? WELL, SENATOR
LAIRD, I ACTUALLY, WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR MEETING WITH ME. AND IT
WAS AN INSPIRED CONVERSATION. I
REALLY ENJOYED IT. I CAN SEE WHY
YOU'VE BEEN SERVING AND WHY
YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB. AND I
THINK THAT THE, I'M TOTALLY
SATISFIED. BASED ON OUR
CONVERSATION AND RECORD. AND THE
ONLY THING I WAS GOING TO ASK
YOU WAS THE PERSPECTIVE YOU
BRING FROM SOMEBODY BECAUSE
YOU'RE IN A CATEGORY OF
APPOINTMENT AND YOU ANSWERED
THAT QUESTION AND YOU ANSWERED
IT WELL. SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN. I WOULD
CONCUR WITH, SENATOR LAIRD. I
MEAN, CERTAINLY YOU'RE YOU'RE ON
AS A PUBLIC MEMBER AND THE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU BRING TO IT
THROUGH YOUR OWN RANCHING
EXPERIENCE, I THINK IS, IS
INVALUABLE. YOU HAVE AS MUCH,
MOTIVATION AS ANYBODY ELSE TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR FORESTS ARE
MANAGED, IN THE APPROPRIATE WAY,
I WILL I WILL ASK, DO YOU, MY
FATHER IN LAW'S A FOREST BOSS UP
IN THE UP IN THE MOUNTAINS.
HAULING OUT TIMBER AND THE TIMES
THAT THEY CAN HAUL AND CAN'T
HAUL. DO YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
THOUGHTS ON ON, SOME OF THE NEW
REGULATIONS THAT WE'VE PUT IN
PLACE HAVING TO DO WITH FIRES,
LIKE, IF IT GETS TOO HOT, YOU
CAN'T, YOU CAN'T BE WORKING
LANDS WITH EQUIPMENT AND ANY
KIND OF IMPACT THAT WILL HAVE,
NOT THAT AS MUCH, YOU KNOW, WE
SET TH¤U. WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE FIRE, AND I WOULDN'T
ADVISE THAT FOR MOST PEOPLE AND,
OR EXTREMELY HOT. SO I KNOW WHAT
HEAT IS NOW AND THAT KIND OF A
SITUATION, BUT, THERE'S MORE
CONCERNS WITH JUST PROCESSING
FACILITIES, BIOMASS, HOW WE GET
THINGS MOVING SO THAT THERE'S A
PLACE FOR BYPRODUCTS TO GO. I
THINK THAT'S MAYBE. I MEAN, I
BROUGHT THE RULES BOOK, AND I
MEAN, I CAN'T READ IT WITH MY
GLASSES ON, IF ANYBODY'S NEVER
SEEN IT, THIS IS SOMETHING
SOMEONE SHOULD GO THROUGH. BUT,
THE RULES FOR BIOMASS. THIS IS
THE RULES FOR THE FORESTRY. SO
THIS IS THE PRACTICE. FOREST
PRACTICE RULES. BUT BUT WITH
THAT, I JUST, I REALLY THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A SPOT
BECAUSE YOU COULD GO OUT, BUT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE FOR YOUR
LOGS TO GO OR FOR YOUR WASTE TO
GO, THEN IT JUST TIES YOUR HANDS.
AND WHEN WE LOGGED ON OUR
PROPERTY, WE WENT UP AND, ONE IT
WAS AN EMERGENCY PERMIT WHICH
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE FASTER, AND
IT WAS, BUT IT STILL COST US
$80,000 TO DO SO. AND THEN,
BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE TO MEET
ALL YOUR WHICH IS FINE. ALL YOUR
ENVIRONMENTAL NEEDS THAT ARE OUT
THERE, BUT JUST THE COST OF
DOING IT, AFTER THAT, WHEN
YOU'RE DONE, YOU HAVE TO PAY THE
TIMBER TAX, WHICH YOU'VE LOST
EVERYTHING. SO TO ME, THAT
DOESN'T MAKE A WHOLE LOT OF
SENSE, BUT ALSO JUST FINDING A
HOME FOR THEM, YOU KNOW,
EVERYTHING HAD BURNED IN THE IN
THE VALLEY AT THAT TIME. AND
AND, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE DON'T WANT
TO BURNED PINE, AND THEY DIDN'T
NEED IT. THEY HAD PLENTY OF
THEIR OWN AND THEN FUR. AND SO
THE MARKET JUST KEPT DROPPING
AS, AS TIME WENT. AND THEN IF
YOU HAVE ANYTHING OVER A LARGE
LIKE IF YOU THINK OF A 28 INCH
TREE, ANYTHING LARGER THAN THAT,
THERE'S VERY FEW MILLS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN TAKE THOSE.
SO OUR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY THE POINT THAT
SLOWS DOWN ANY ANYBODY FROM
BEING ABLE TO, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
YOU HAVE 15 ACRES, A HUNDRED
ACRES OR 5000 ACRES OF TIMBER,
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A HOME FOR IT,
THEN YOU'RE REALLY IN A IN A
HARD POSITION. I KNOW THE RURAL,
RURAL COUNTIES ASSOCIATION HAS
GOT SOME PLANS FOR BIOMASS. DO
YOU WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THEM AT ALL? NOT NOT NO, NOT,
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THERE IS ONE
I READ IN YUBA CITY THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE COMING ONLINE,
AND I THINK IT THEN IT'S JUST
THE COST, YOU KNOW, ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET ENOUGH
AND MAYBE THEY'RE THEY'LL GET
SOME ALMOND HULLS AND SOME
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WILL BOOST
THAT ENERGY BECAUSE THAT WOULD
HELP THEM. BUT THERE'S THREE UP
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY. AND I DON'T
KNOW THAT ANY OF THOSE ARE STILL
RUNNING JUST BECAUSE OF THE COST
OF KEEPING THEM GOING AS WELL.
YEAH. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
THANKS FOR BEING WILLING TO
SERVE. OH, THANK YOU, SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU. I REPRESENT
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. AND WHAT AND
THE RURAL PART OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WHEN A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA DON'T KNOW IS THAT
THERE IS SEVERAL THOUSAND HEAD
OF CATTLE, RAISED IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY. SO I'M INTERESTED, AS
YOU'RE WORKING THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, THE CATTLE GRAZING
SITUATION, ANYTHING I CAN DO TO
BE HELPFUL IN THAT, PLEASE DON'T
HESITATE TO REACH OUT TO MY
OFFICE. AND ALSO LOOKING FORWARD
TO YOUR CONFIRMATION TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
I JUST HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION. YOU SAID THAT THERE'S
THREE, MILLS IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY,
BUT THEY'RE NOT OPERATIONAL
BECAUSE OF THE COST. WAS THAT
BECAUSE OF POLICY PASSED OUT OF
THIS BUILDING? WE USED TO HAVE
SEVERAL TIMBER, OPERATIONS, NOT
MILLS, BUT BIOMASS. SO BIOMASS,
BIOMASS. SO BIOMASS. BIOMASS. SO
IS IT THE COST? YOU SAID $80,000
FOR A PERMIT. IS THAT FOR A
BIOMASS THAT'S 80,000 WAS SO
THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY LOG THE
TIMBER OFF OF OUR PROPERTY AFTER
IT ALL BURNED, YOU WERE CHARGED
$80,000. BY WHO OR BY WHAT
AGENCY? PROFESSIONAL FOR
FORESTER. SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
FORESTER THAT KNOWS ALL OF THESE
RULES THAT ARE IN THIS BOOK. AND
THEN THEY DO A PLAN FOR US, AND
THEN WE SUBMIT IT TO CAL FIRE
AND IT GOES THROUGH THE PROCESS.
AND THEN YOU'RE ABLE YOU'RE ABLE
TO LOG. BUT JUST THE COST, JUST
THE PERMIT, JUST THE PERMIT SO
THAT YOU CAN GO THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR YOU TO TAKE BURNED TREES OFF
YOUR PROPERTY. CORRECT CORRECT.
OKAY. JUST THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS SOUNDS LIKE A BILL. AND
THEN JUST. YEAH. AND JUST OUT OF
CURIOSITY, AND IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION, YOU
DON'T HAVE TO. WHAT WAS THE COST
TO HAVE THE CONTRACTOR REMOVE
THE DEAD TREES? WE PAID, IT WAS
200. SO THEY DO IT BY, BY BOARD
FEET AND LOADS LOG LOADS. AND SO
I WANT TO SAY HE WAS $230. WE
PROBABLY LOGGED, $1 MILLION
WORTH AND PROBABLY CAME OUT WITH
ABOUT 300,000. AND THAT'S NOT
MINUS THE EXPENSES WHEN WE WERE
DONE. AND A LOT OF IT COULDN'T
LEAVE THE PROPERTY BECAUSE WHEN
PINE STARTS TO TURN BLUE, WHEN
IT WHEN IT DIES, THEY'LL GET AND
IT LOOKS REALLY PRETTY IN THE
STORES, BUT THEY DON'T PAY FOR
IT. SO WHEN PINE SITS STANDS TOO
LONG IT'LL TURN BLUE ON THE
INSIDE. AND SO THEN THE
COMPANIES DON'T WANT IT ANYMORE.
SO YOU END UP LEAVING. WE ENDED
UP LEAVING MORE BEHIND THAN WE
WISHED TO. CAN I ASK A
CLARIFYING QUESTION ON THAT REAL
QUICK? ABSOLUTELY. ON THE BLUE.
IS IT BECAUSE IT'S DETERIORATING
AND IT'S NOT AS THE QUALITY OF
IT'S NOT AS GOOD, OR IT'S JUST
THE APPEARANCE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE
THE APPEARANCE. I THINK IT'S
JUST THE APPEARANCE. I MEAN,
THERE DOES COME A TIME WHEN THE
LOGS ARE GOING TO DETERIORATE,
BUT IT, YOU KNOW, IT CAN TAKE 3
TO 6 MONTHS AND THEN THEY'RE,
THEY'LL, THEY'LL TURN BLUE. AND
OF COURSE RIGHT AFTER 18 AND 29
OUR FIRE HIT IN AUGUST INTO
JULY. AUGUST. IT WASN'T IT WAS A
LONG FIRE, BY THE TIME WE GOT UP
THERE TO GET READY TO LOG, IT
STARTED RAINING AND WE HAD 60IN
OF RAIN ON THE RANCH THAT YEAR.
SO THAT PUT OUT OUR ABILITY TO
LOG UNTIL MAY, IF WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO ACTUALLY LOG IN
NOVEMBER, WHEN, IF IT WAS STAYED
DRY AND BE ABLE TO GET IN THERE
AND DO SO, THEN WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN PROBABLY ABLE TO, YOU KNOW,
GET RID OF MORE OF THAT BECAUSE
WE WERE GOING TO TAKE THE PINE
FIRST, BECAUSE THAT'S THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND THEN GO TO THE,
TO THE FIR. BUT YOU KNOW, AS
LUCK WOULD HAVE IT. YEAH. SO
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE GOVERNOR'S, ASK A REQUEST TO
BE ON THIS, APPOINTMENT, I THINK
YOU BRING WORLD WORLD, REAL
WORLD EXPERIENCE. TO THE BOARD.
A LOT OF TIMES, POLICY MAKERS,
LIKE ALL OF US, MAKE POLICY, AND
WE'VE NEVER HAD ANY EXPERIENCE
IN IN THE POLICY THAT WE'RE
OVERSEEING, REGARDLESS OF WHAT
IT IS. AND SO I JUST APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE AND LIFE EXPERIENCE
TO THIS BOARD. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR APPOINTMENT,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE DÍAS? WE'LL GO TO
MEMBERS IN THE AUDIENCE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM IN SUPPORT ANY OF
THOSE IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION, ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE DÍAS FOR A
MOTION OR A CONVERSATION. I
WOULD MOVE APPROVAL AND THAT WE
FORWARD THE NOMINATION TO THE
FLOOR FOR FORMAL CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU, SENATOR LAIRD, MADAM
SECRETARY, YOU WANT TO CALL THE
ROLL MCGUIRE GROVE? I GROVE I
EGGMAN, I EGGMAN, I JONES A
JONES I LAIRD I LAIRD I 4 TO 0
ON CALL. THANK YOU, MRS. DELBAR.
AND, I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
YOUR CONFIRMATION ON THE FLOOR.
AND THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. AND JUST BRINGING SOME
COMMON SENSE TO A SITUATION THAT
REALLY, DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. THANK YOU. AND I'M
SORRY TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR FIRE. I
KNOW IT'S HARD. IT'S HARD. IT'S
DIFFICULT. AND I STILL HAVE ONE
COW THAT I JUST WON'T LET
ANYBODY GET RID OF THAT WE GOT
OUT OF THE FIRE AND MY KIDS ARE
ALWAYS LIKE, MOM, SHE'S SHE'S
NOT PRODUCING A CALF. SHE'S JUST
SHE'S I SAID, I DON'T CARE. SHE
EARNED IT. SO SHE'S STAYING.
SHE'S STAYING HERE. I CAN SHOW
YOU A PICTURE OF A CALF I PUT IN
THE MUDROOM AND MY HUSBAND GOES,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING? I KNOW IT'S
EITHER GOING TO LIVE OR DIE.
HE'S ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT'S
LIKE, IT SERVES A PURPOSE OR IT
DOESN'T. AND I'M LIKE, LEAVE IT
ALONE. I'M CALLING THE VET.
THAT'S RIGHT. EXACTLY. GOOD FOR
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. WE ARE, I THINK.
IS THAT IT? EXECUTIVE OKAY. OKAY
HUESO COMING UP. OKAY, SO THAT
IS THE CONCLUSION OF OUR REGULAR
RULES COMMITTEE. WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS, AND WE WILL
BE GOING INTO EXECUTIVE SESSION.
WELL LET'S WAIT. OH, LET'S JUST
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS. WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A BRIEF RECESS AND
WAIT FOR THE PRO TEM TO COME
BACK. THANK YOU. SORRY.
30S ARE WE STILL ON IT? WE'RE
GOOD. OH WE'RE GOOD. SORRY THE
RULES COMMITTEE WILL RECONVENE
NOW. WE ARE GOING TO OPEN THE
ROLL. MADAM SECRETARY, ON
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS REQUIRED
TO APPEAR, ITEMS A, B AND C.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE
GROVE. I GROVE. I 3 TO 0, 3 TO
0. THAT MOVES TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. AND THEN WE CAN CLOSE
OUT, AND THEN WE CAN CLOSE THAT
OUT. WERE THERE ANY OTHER. CAN
YOU HELP ME OUT, MADAM SECRETARY?
WERE THERE ANY OTHER. OKAY. SO
ITEM D, ITEM D. YEAH. WE NEED TO
CLOSE THAT. ROLL ONE. WE JUST
DID. YES. OH. ITEM D WE NEED TO
CLOSE THE ROLL ON ITEM D OR CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AGAIN MCGUIRE
4 TO 0. WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
ON THAT. IS THAT COVER ALL OF
OUR ITEMS TODAY. THEN WE WILL
ADJOURN FOR THE DAY, OUR LAST
RULES COMMITTEE HEARING FOR THE
YEAR. AND WE WILL MOVE INTO
EXECUTIVE SESSION.